the winners of love island 2019 are Zack
and Elizabeth
[Music]
I know this is supposed to be a
difficult decision but it really hasn't
been night obviously yeah I mean this is
truly incredible I'm so grateful for
this experience I'm so grateful for all
the friendships that I've gained in here
I'm so grateful for this land the world
to me and I can't wait to experience the
life outside of here with her honestly
we're gonna have a great night I just
didn't see this coming I thought that
exact same sentence in my head I was
gonna say it if she didn't you're
probably gonna get married in like six
months
no I don't know right now we're just
taking things one step at a time I think
we are both at points in our lives where
we need to evaluate what we're gonna do
and what steps were going to take but
we're gonna be there for each other
supporting each other so whatever
happens happens but we got each other's
backs at the end of the day meeting me
yeah meeting meeting Elizabeth was
amazing and one of my favorite parts of
this whole journey was when Elizabeth
got asked to go out on a date and she
came back from that date and we had this
little moment in the bathroom and that's
like when I knew that this relationship
was gonna be what it was that was just
like one of our I think defining moments
in here and I'll never forget that
moment
we just both
yeah we didn't want to be a part I I'm
probably gonna use most of my money
because I have some student loans to pay
off and and then I'd like to like start
a business with with with if I have
money left over I like to start start my
own business so I cannot wait to just
explore with you and I'm just so happy
[Music]